The joe rogan experience.
Some guys go into acting,
you know Gina Gershon is
like a famous actress now.
Gina Gershon.
Gina.
Goddammit it.
What's her name?
Gina Carano.
Gina Gershon's,
obviously a famous actress too.
Um,
there was another rumor
that Clinton fucked her too.
That's why it was good fallen all this
little g's went and fucked everybody love
him.
The last,
the last American presidential,
Dick's Leaner Ladies and gentlemen,
dude was they say he's smashed out.
Liz Hurley.
Yeah.
This is a picture of
them stare at each other.
Look in each other's eyes and you look,
oh yeah,
for sure.
It's just too romantic.
The look,
the them looking at each
other and it wasn't at times.
Tom Sizemore.
That was dry snitching.
He was,
yes.
He was a dry snitch up
that dirty son of a bitch.
That Nigga is a snitch.
He is.
That's what I said.
That's the first thing I said on the Fred.
I said,
what this tells me is that Tom Sizemore
can't keep the fucking secret dude.
Yeah,
that's weak.
I told Mary and you go on
throw bill under the bus.
There's a picture.
Come on,
son.
Look in his eyes.
No one escapes that deck.
That deck is takes an octopus,
comes out and grabs everything.
Looking at him.
I mean that is like a
dominant submissive picture.
If ever people were not touching,
but one was encroaching
Ludas body language.
He's leaning towards her.
Look at her.
Look at her left shoulder.
Turn slightly away from him.
She wants to lay down right now.
Look at her list.
Oh,
dirty.
Too dirty.
Dirty,
dirty people.
I love it.
I wish I was there.
I'd beat off in the corner.
I wouldn't say it
slick willy.
Tearing it up.
I don't know how we got on that subject.
We were talking about Mike Tyson.
Beat the fuck out of people.
Just rude.
Tremendous.
You'll need to fuck up the picture
and we're putting Hillary in there.
Get that picture down.
You don't need to fuck
up all of our minds.
But thinking about the guilt that he
must have suffered right after he nutted
non worth it.
Shit.
Oh Kiss.
I mean she knows.
She knows
she,
you
look at her fuck.
Oh my God.
Look at that woman.
Oh Wow.
They play dress up.
Look,
Paul Revere's right behind
them to get that woman.
That woman's a hater.
No,
the woman right there,
you get up to her.
Look at that.
She knows.
She knows is the classic.
She's either face.
She got the Dick.
I did it.
She does what's going on under the table.
As soon as they got in their car,
her and her husband,
she was like that motherfucker.
Did you see the way he
kissed Elizabeth Hurley?
Oh,
he's such a pig.
I despise him rush.
Limbaugh's right.
Look at him.
You know what's funny though,
when I,
when I heard about this,
it was so interesting that I heard
conservatives come out the woodwork.
Um,
who was it?
I think it was rand Paul was like,
Oh man,
this is terrible.
The president should apologize,
but wait a minute homie.
Where were you when Newt
Gingrich was running for office?
Because didn't he drop his wife and then
deal with another woman and then deal
with another one?
Isn't that,
that,
that the,
the benchmark of men that are in power,
they're just looking to play.
Gotcha.
All these shit heads.
Are they just using that like it's points
on a blanket and nobody ever fucked?
No,
they scored on you.
They caught you,
They got points now and they just can
use those points to try to shut you down
and build them up.
But it all just makes everybody
look like a bunch of bitches.
Because if that was going
on amongst your friends,
let's say if there was 10 of your
friends and one of your friends was not
particularly happy with
his wife's relationship,
and so he started banging Elizabeth Hurley
and all you guys found out about it,
I wouldn't dry snitch if he would play
Tom Sizemore I'll tell you went out and
you,
you snitch.
No one would want to hang
out with you anymore.
He'd be like,
what the fuck tech?
But come on man.
Who's going to party
with Tom Sizemore now?
Not me.
I'll tell you that Tom.
Go Fuck yourself pal.
[inaudible] keep a motherfucker.
Okay.